These two rules here form what is known more formally as the Collatz series
named after the German mathematician Lothar Collatz and appeared somewhat erratic
as I think you've seen with the program.
Sometimes it will terminate very quickly for certain values of i
and sometimes actually it will behave super eratic and it will go up and down and up and down
until it finally terminates.
Now here's the thing, it has been conjectured that this algorithm here will terminate
for any value of i but so far nobody has been able to prove that.
So if we were given an integer for this function here for which the Collatz hypothesis
that this algorithm here always terminates has not been verified
then that would indeed be undecidable.
Now truth be told, it would have to be a very large integer because the Collatz hypothesis
has been verified for large numbers indeed.
Nevertheless, once the integer is out of this range, we have no way of deciding
whether this algorithm would terminate or not.
The only thing we can do is run it so the Collatz problem or the Collatz hypothesis
is an open mathematical problem and of course as you know it's not the only
open mathematical problem so we could have other mathematical problems as well.
But I want to show you something.
So if we have an algorithm that solves the halting problem, so if we indeed had this algorithm halt
what we could then do for example is write the following program for i = 1 to 10¹⁰⁰
then run the Collatz rules for i so we start with i = 1 then we go to i = 2 and so on
and then we feed this problem into the halting algorithm.
And now if the halting algorithm says yes, then this means that the Collatz hypothesis is true
for any number from 1 to 10¹⁰⁰ and if it says no then it means that there is some number
for which the Collatz hypothesis is not true, which means that this part here
would go into an infinite loop and then we can easily
check this for larger and larger and larger numbers.
An algorithm that would be able to solve the halting problem
would actually be able to solve almost any open mathematical problem there is out there.
Any mathematical problem that can be formulated as an algorithm
could be decided by an algorithm that solves the halting problem.
So this would almost be a kind of omission algorithm which also provides an intuition
why this halting algorithm here cannot possibly exist.
It would just simply be too powerful.
It could answer almost any mathematical question that we can think of.